spending this week with our guys and
we're talking about leadership and all
this other stuff and
each
decade i asked myself different
questions and in that decade that
question was the most important question
do you know what i'm saying like
when you're teens you're asking
man you know whatever the question may
be in your teens you know when can i
grow up when i want to when am i going
to go when am i going to be cool when am
i going to be have a girlfriend when can
i go whatever questions you ask okay am
i going to get a job am i going to do
that ok in your 20s you asked different
questions in your 30s you ask different
questions in your 40s you have different
questions certain questions are constant
right
what's my purpose why am i here what am
i doing what do you want me to do what's
what am i supposed to do how am i in the
right position i'm at right now mind the
career certain questions are going to be
constant right
but certain questions as you age
the weight gets heavier and it gets more
important to you at that age than it did
a decade or two or three decades ago i
think that's undoubtedly true well what
is the question that's the heaviest for
you at your age because you just turned
80. so i only can tell you what's the
most heaviest question of my age but
what is the heaviest question at your
age being 80 i don't know what it is to
be 80 i only know what it is to be 43.
the heaviest question heaviest question
by yourself you don't you don't mean the
questions that inevitably possess people
my age
digestion health
social security those aren't the
questions you're talking i'm not i'm by
the way but by the way that's also good
for me to know because
you know i'm talking to a guy when i was
in my 20s i'm trying to figure out if i
want to get married or not because i was
actually contemplating even ever getting
married i enjoy my own company i don't
know if i want to get married so i had
to really
make sense of does this marriage thing
make sense for me maybe it does for
other people maybe it doesn't for me it
was a very difficult question so i'd go
around asking people the questions and
then finally i came down to a point of
no matter who you marry there's a risk
and it's a risk i'm willing to take and
here's how i'm can hedge my risk but no
matter who i'm married there's gonna be
a risk right and then one i'm listening
to this uh husband and wife who in their
60s
late 60s and then i'm listening to this
husband and wife who just got married in
their 20s and i'm listening to this guy
that's early 20s single than somebody
that's divorced in their 40s and they're
all talking about marriage
and relationship
and eventually this 68 year old husband
and wife says you know when i was in my
20s 30s i thought it was all about sex
and let me tell you what happened then
health happened then this happened then
health happened to me
and i was you know
health happened to my wife first and i
was complaining to her because my wife
couldn't have sex with me for nine
months
and then nine months later the moment we
could have sex then health happened to
me and i felt so embarrassed because i
judged her so much and then you're like
oh interesting so maybe one day you're
gonna go through
some of these things would help so i
learned as a man as i'm aging right i'm
trying to learn from you
set those questions aside
what are some heavy questions that you
know get you thinking at this age you
lived a pretty good life i can complain
certainly not
i could complain but i shan't
um
i think the question
the really heavy questions are sorrowful
questions at my age
and
one of the experiences of anyone who has
lived the kind of life that i've lived
is the discovery that
inexorably one has
put a certain distance between
what one is doing in my case writing
and the audience one hope to see
that is the separation begins the minute
you publish something you attract
certain readers you repel other readers
that's a normal point of equilibrium
the further you progress in any kind of
literary life
on the one hand you may if you're lucky
cement a reputation
achieve a certain loyal readership but
inevitably you discover that
thrill of reaching an audience
is disappointed because
you are inevitably writing for the past
that at my age
i can no no no longer be a fresh voice
and therefore no longer attract new
readers
that's exactly how it should be
why because of your age you're saying
people are going to be less interested
they are less interesting
that's not the case for bernie sanders
nobody gave her two craps about him for
decades and all of a sudden of the past
five ten years he's the you know one of
the biggest
lucky bernie do you think that's luck
i don't know but that's conviction and
hard work
but continue i'm curious could be a
combination of the bible but i think
every writer has the same experience
that at a certain point even philip roth
at a certain point that vivid intense
relationship with an audience that every
writer imagines is out there palpitating
waiting hanging on your every word that
disappears and i certainly feel that in
my own case
i'm not complaining i have readers
that's not the point
but in a larger sense i've lost an
audience
and everything about me
is suggestive
of anachronism that is a time before the
present time and again that's inevitable
one can be at the pre in the present
completely in the present only at a
certain age the age of discovery say
from 15 to 30 or 15 to 35.
so when you talk about
what are some of the deeper aspects of
being 80
early middle aged as i remarked earlier
that sorrowful discovery that hey look
you are about to begin the process of
outliving your time
nothing wrong with that
nothing wrong with that but it is not a
joyous experience that discovery
neither should it be terribly sorrowful
it's sorrowful but it shouldn't be
terribly sorrowful their compensations
if you enjoyed this short clip click
over here to watch another short clip
and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]